[Música]
les pido que conmigo imaginen ya mismo
en este momento que en todo este
auditorio está toda la población del
mundo lo pueden imaginar somos todo el
mundo en este auditorio lo tienen si lo
tienen ahora lo voy a pedir a la gente
que está en la primera fila que levanten
sus manos levanten sus manos la gente de
la segunda fila por favor levanten sus
manos la gente de la tercera levanten
sus manos la gente de la cuarta fila
levanten sus manos y finalmente los de
la quinta fila levanten en sus manos
sostengan las por favor miren a su
alrededor
miren centro ustedes y al resto del
auditorio le pido que mire también hacia
adelante cuántos son
listo ustedes representan en este
momento unos 2000 millones de personas
es un número grande muy grande como
decimos los científicos en córdoba es un
montonazo de gente
bajen sus manos muchas gracias
2000 millones de personas en este
momento en todo el mundo están
transitando el espacio de tiempo que va
entre la infancia y la adultez son los
adolescentes ok
muchos trabajando por primera vez y con
ese primer trabajo contribuyendo de
manera significativa al sustento de sus
familias otros trabajando de manera
sostenida y de manera muy importante
dentro de sus comunidades siendo quizás
referentes sociales o políticos incluso
algunos también enfrentando el desafío
tal vez de ser padres son madres
claramente los problemas que enfrentan
los adolescentes de hoy son muchos y son
más complejos que los que enfrentamos
los adultos en el pasado y esa es una de
las razones por las cuales como sociedad
como colectivo debemos empezar a pensar
estrategias para promover su bienestar y
asegurar el mejor desarrollo posible
pero hay una dificultad la dificultad
tiene que ver con que no todos nos
ponemos de acuerdo en definir qué es ser
adolescente en tener una definición de
adolescencia cada uno de los que estamos
aquí tiene un ideal respecto padres
maestros investigadores e incluso a cada
adolescente es ahí donde tal vez quizás
las ciencias del cerebro la psicología
las neurociencias pueden construir con
algunos elementos para empezar a armar
el rompecabezas que representa la
adolescencia dije rompecabezas no dolor
de cabezas porque a veces también lo son
en ese desafío
ya sabemos por suerte gracias justamente
a la contribución de muchas disciplinas
que hay muchos cambios y muy
significativos tanto psicológicos
sociales incluso económicos y biológicos
particularmente durante la adolescencia
por ejemplo sabemos muy particularmente
que el cerebro experimenta no solamente
profundos cambios en su estructura sino
también en cómo funciona y estos cambios
en su estructura y en su funcionamiento
van asociados con cambios significativos
también en el comportamiento de los
adolescentes y el otro desafío que
tenemos en relación a esa información es
que todo esto no ocurre de manera lineal
de manera simultánea sí y esto nos ayuda
a entender una de las primeras cosas que
es que por ejemplo la corteza frontal
que es la parte más anterior nuestro
cerebro está justo detrás de nuestra
frente y que es la responsable de la
expresión de nuestra personalidad y de
ayudarnos a tomar decisiones complejas y
algunas no tan complejas pero que tienen
implicancias significativas como por
ejemplo ayudarnos a decidir si usar
medias con ojotas es una buena idea o no
esa corteza prefrontal nos ayuda a este
tipo de cosas y tiene que ver también
con la capacidad de tomar decisiones
aspecto que también está relacionado con
algo que es fundamental para nosotros
que es nuestras emociones las emociones
dependen de otra parte del cerebro que
llamamos sistema límbico
las dos tienen que jugar de manera con
jugada de manera coordinada y van a
lograr eso recién mucho más tarde en el
desarrollo cuando uno es adulto esto nos
ayuda a entender por qué justamente los
adolescentes presentan muchas
dificultades en la regulación de sus
emociones y en la capacidad justamente
de tomar decisiones el sistema límbico
por otro lado no solamente está
implicado en cómo regulamos emociones o
cómo procesamos las emociones también
está implicado nuestro aspecto
fundamental para nosotros que es cómo
respondemos a las recompensas a las
cosas que nos gustan por eso también los
adolescentes están particularmente
orientados a la búsqueda del placer y
por lo mismo están implicados
fuertemente en comportamientos riesgosos
y eso los puede llevar a que por ejemplo
exploren con drogas deciden tener sexo
sin protección o piensen que puede ser
una muy buena idea tirarse en patineta a
contramano por una calle principal de la
ciudad donde vive todo esto es
fundamental y nos tiene que ayudar a
entender que es natural los cambios en
el comportamiento de riesgo la
impulsividad los problemas para regular
emociones o las dificultades para
regular emociones son aspectos naturales
del desarrollo de los adolescentes es
fundamental que los adolescentes lo
tengan presente y también que lo
empezamos a tener presente en los
adultos para encontrar formas más
positivas de lidiar con estas
características de los adolescentes
en esta línea justamente nos podemos
preguntar cuál es la contribución de la
psicología de las neurociencias de las
denominadas ciencias del cerebro para
mejorar la sociedad en general y
particularmente por las características
que les acabo de contar para la
población adolescente que es una
población muy vulnerable y en riesgo
eso nos lleva y empezamos a revisar qué
podemos hacer
bueno en algunos países por ejemplo en
eeuu en uruguay no muy lejos de aquí ya
hay algunas iniciativas pensadas para
mejorar el bienestar de los adolescentes
muy sencillas por ejemplo una anoten las
maestras y los directores es retrasar
dos horas de inicio de clases con esa
medida tan sencilla se generan dos
efectos que son dramáticos y que son muy
fáciles de establecer primero mejorar
rápidamente el rendimiento académico o
las notas o los problemas de aprendizaje
de los adolescentes y segundo mejora el
bienestar general de los adolescentes
porque este es otro dato importante no
solamente el cerebro de los adolescentes
es diferente del cerebro de los adultos
también la forma en que duermen el sueño
de los adolescentes diferentes de los
adultos ok hay otras iniciativas o
acciones sencillas que generalmente
asociamos con la mejora del bienestar de
las adolescentes pero que hoy sabemos
justamente que también ayudan no
solamente a mejorar aspectos físicos de
los adolescentes sino sus capacidades
cognitivas
por ejemplo la práctica del deporte si
el fútbol las artes marciales pueden
ayudar a los adolescentes a que mejoren
su capacidad de tomar decisiones a que
aprendan a regular las emociones y que
que descubran la importancia de cooperar
con otros también anoten los papás los
videojuegos pueden ayudar a mejorar la
capacidad de tomar decisiones la
capacidad atencional y la capacidad
también incluso de regular emociones de
las adolescentes aprender a programar
robots saber algo de instrumentos
musicales sin tener que ser un
profesional también son actividades e
iniciativas que nuestros adolescentes
pueden desplegar y que pueden ayudarlos
a justamente a mejorar lo que los
psicólogos llamamos funciones ejecutivas
la capacidad de tomar decisiones acordes
o reguladas en sintonía con nuestras
emociones
efectivamente la psicología las ciencias
del cerebro las neurociencias han
construido de manera sistemática a que
hoy sepamos muchísimo sobre las
características de los cambios
cerebrales que se experimentan durante
la adolescencia y de los comportamientos
que son específicos de esta etapa del
desarrollo sin embargo como sociedad
todavía nos quedan muchas preguntas por
responder y muchos problemas por
resolver
quizás en la búsqueda de soluciones un
primer paso significativo sea que cada
adolescente sepa qué pasa por sus
cabezas y no solo no solamente eso sino
que cada uno de los adultos también sepa
qué es lo que ocurre dentro del cerebro
de los adolescentes porque una sociedad
que no comprende ni apoya a sus
adolescentes es una sociedad que no
tiene futuro
[Aplausos]
[Música]